in terms of music do you do like
everything on your own as well like are
you
like are you experiencing all like the
beat making and all that because i'm i'm
[ __ ] garbage at all of that yeah
conor is like mega monkey brain
so i yeah i i saw that you did a rap
competition
right and i think one of the people who
got to the final was someone that we've
done raps for
like josh and like joshua yeah yeah yeah
a little remix competition
right debut song and i saw what dj joe
was in there
was in there as well yeah and uh i i've
so we've done raps before
uh but uh i so joey actually you write
your own raps and perform them right yes
i'm so [ __ ] terrible i have no rhythm
that i have to ask him to write it and
then i have to ask him to record
him doing it and then i'll mimic it oh
really yeah yeah i literally
you you just basically got a chichi yeah
like because even if they give me the
wrap i actually don't
know how to wrap it like i'm i'm i'm
reading the flow of it
yeah i read it like a businessman
reading like an accounting page you know
how do i do that how do i get better
because i'm [ __ ] terrible at all of
this
well i mean interestingly enough um
everyone starts out being
f-wording terrible sorry i really
shouldn't curse anyone you can cut us
off
it's all right i can is it okay no he's
totally good you're mad
okay hold on
everyone starts out bad that's the truth
even even i started out very bad back in
the day
back in the day but um and that's why i
was afraid to start
repping actually um because i had
already gotten so good at
killing folks right right right why
change your day job right yeah exactly i
mean i'm already good at this right so
why would i switch to something that i'm
not
good at or that i know i'm not skilled
at um but i was
so inspired i suppose by well multiple
people mostly
in the underworlds rap scene i would say
um is very low-key and as you would
expect
they really inspired me a lot and i
decided well i might as well give it a
try so i did
and over time uh you get better and even
listening back to my old things um yeah
terrible like garbage absolutely garbage
like there's no there's no sugarcoating
right but i mean the advice that i give
is always the same cliche stuff that you
hear all the time but it worked for me
listen
you just gotta you just gotta keep going
even if you suck and if you suck you
keep trying because if you quit when you
suck that's a real shame because
you stop doing it and you suck you still
suck forever yeah i mean i bet i think
the best advice you can give anyone
to like learn any skill set is just to
do it and just to try and just keep
trying yeah
it's it's true when it comes to rapping
and it's true when it comes to making
youtube videos
i mean because whatever i definitely
like the first couple of raps that i did
for like
josh or like any other like collaborator
that i did like yeah i look back and i'm
just like man that was that was that was
a [ __ ]
that's like me out five minutes i got
that [ __ ] yeah but the latest
stuff i did i was like my boy's spitting
bars
i'm still trying to make people forget
that i once took part in like the
uh was it the annie oh can we can we
show you guard
no can we do something is that a real
thing that i can watch
okay yeah so so this is like a community
thing that we used to do every year
where
it's called the anatube cipher that's
what it's called and basically
it's like the enemy cipher yeah the
anime cyber so like one person would
find a beat like a like a creative
commons beat yeah and then
spit like an eight bar or a 16 or
whatever and then they would tag
another anituber to be like all right
now you have to like respond i'm getting
brand new i'm [ __ ] leaving if we're
getting this out there
and so like what was this like you did
it like what 2018
yeah 2017 2017 i think 2017 and 28 hours
i forgot which one it was but that was
the year where like the most amount of
vandertubers did yeah and of course
god got tagged like 60 million times
yeah and so he joined in
and uh his bars though it's it's where
they
we'll link it in the description as well
just in case you want to hear the whole
thing
what was it it's like it's that
[ __ ] tea
i've i've wiped that rap from my memory
and i
[ __ ] hate everyone for mentioning
that now did it
do a bonus video where you react to all
of our apps i think that would be fun
that would be fun yeah yeah yeah that
sounds cool i'm down
i hate you i am down h i hate you all
right now
i gotta ask there's a death god do you
have a favorite meme mimi a
meme whichever you prefer pronunciation
i don't want to die gosh
it's okay can you kill me right now
i'm sorry i had to do that too this is
like the parent pulling out like the
baby photos with the dick
look how tiny his date was sorry sorry
shouldn't talk about unsightly things
around to death go sir oh it's fine you
can talk about whatever you like
oh okay that's good were you like
nervous to debut your first song
oh yes definitely i well because you all
can tell i have
i'm very different sounding right i have
a very
mod interesting style it's kind of
you certainly have a distinct like voice
like rapping voice definitely for sure
so yeah i was pretty nervous i didn't
know how people were going to receive it
right um so that was a big worry i
thought that there would be
um a lot of backlash against it for
whatever reason
um i also just hold myself to a really
really high standard so
uh listening back to my rep again i was
like is this really any good
i don't know to be fair though you set
it up really nicely because like you
kind of like
hinted like during your stream because i
remember i was watching your debut
stream again yesterday
and you debuted your first song on the
debut yeah right
and like i think the way you like kind
of set yourself up being like you know
i'm just like you know trying this rap
thing and then the song starts and
people are like all right well you know
she sounds nervous i'm not going to
expect like the most amazing rap but
it's still going to be cute anyway
and then three seconds later you're just
like spitting like this insane flow and
i'm just like holy [ __ ]
oh yeah i mean you gotta lower those
expectations first am i right
exactly exactly like if you had set
yourself up being like yeah yeah i could
write
[ __ ] yeah i'm the [ __ ] yeah yeah that's
hustling yeah then then it would have
been like all right but
i think you went into it really nicely
thanks